foreign
in this video we will see who is a
business analyst by discussing various
roles and responsibilities a business
analysis handles but before we begin
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn business
analysis involves identifying and
analyzing business problems and
opportunities and recommending solutions
that aligns with an organization's goals
and objectives this process often
involves gathering and analyzing data
creating models and reports and
communicating findings to stakeholders a
business analyst is a professional who
works with an organization to identify
analyze and solve problems they use
their expertise in data analysis
modeling and communication to help
organizations improve their processes
products and services business analyst
of even work closely with stakeholders
across various departments to ensure
Project's access so if you are looking
to become a certified business analyst
check simply learns postgraduate program
in business analysis with this program
you will learn how to tackle complex
problems using in-demand tools you will
learn various skills in business
analysis like L citation and
collaboration BRD frd and SRS document
creation requirement analysis planning
and monitoring requirement life cycle
management and more with this you again
expertise On Tools like Ms Excel jira
power bi are MySQL and more so hurry up
and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced youth success
in their career listen to their
experience find the simply dance course
reviews in the description
so without any further Ado let's begin
and start knowing who is business
analyst and responsibilities a business
analysis handles business analyst is a
professional who is responsible for
Bridging the Gap between it and business
teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-function requirements in a business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem so let's have a look at the top
skills to become a successful business
analyst the first skill we have is
understanding the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increasing marketing budget according to
the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill of business
analysts should have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says
five percent of the people think 10
percent of the people think they think
and the other 85 percent would rather
die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts require good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders non-verbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills business analysts
also perform cost benefit analysis to
conduct an assessment of the benefits
and costs anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have a knack to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation date of wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deeply tidier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
now business analyst should be
proficient in using various business
intelligence tools for creating reports
and dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualize Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboot reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth scale in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution so here we wrap up
this short video on who a business
analyst is by covering rules and
responsibilities of business analysis
stay tuned with us for more videos
thanks for watching this video
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here